if you don't have money to tip your
server and you go out to eat and don't
tip your server I have zero respect for
you I am a server making five something
an hour and I live off of your tip I
don't care how many tables I have how
busy I look
I don't care nine times out of ten I'm
not making the money that you think I'm
making and it's crazy because there's so
many servers out there and there's no
awareness for this it feels like like
the server industry does not get enough
credit for how hard this [ __ ] is it is
not easy it's back breaking work
thing I haven't worked in the industry
and I didn't having to rely on that
um
it's fun when you make tips
it's fun being
on a tip when you make money it's not
when you don't when people don't tip and
the thing that people forget sometimes
is that well here in Canada the Tipping
is
not mandatory actually it's very
suggested but it goes according to the
service that you have if you work at a
spot and your manager doesn't put enough
people on that spot and then your tip
suffers your tip suffers because you
cannot cater to all those fables
sometimes I don't tip not because I have
to tip and some servers like taking in
they they take it as you have to tip I
actually have to tip according to the
service if your service was bad it goes
with the service that's what the thing
is with tipping you understand and I I
went to a restaurant and when one of my
friends didn't tip and then the server
came back and it's like was there
something wrong with the service and I
think that that's the proper way to go
about that when you don't receive the
amount of tips that you think you can be
like
was there something wrong with the
service if the person goes no Then There
goes your problem but if the person says
yeah there was which my friend did you
did this that that that that that orders
was wrong and that that so now I didn't
give you 15. I gave you 10.
you got a tip
so there's this there's a thing about
The Tipping thing there's really a thing
about that now there's a whole other
conversation to have if
we should have tips or we shouldn't
that's a whole other conversation I
think that we shouldn't have tips your
page your wage and you should accept
that and in your paycheck it should be
included the tip should be included
right
and then after that if the client wants
to give you more to give you more but
other than that that's that that's the
different conversation to have in the
same you know thing I work in a bar and
grill and I love my
life might be wrong and I'm good at what
I do but it is so degrading to get
stiffed
to work so hard to smile at a table with
a big smile on my face despite how
stressed I am and give you good service
and then get no tip like I didn't just
work my ass off for you
they were good days and there are bad
days and today is a bad day and I think
that the service service industry needs
better
um
okay because lately society's just not
getting it if a stripper makes money
on good days she makes money on good
days and on bad days sometimes she's
gonna be put by clients
that's the name of the game and you
chose that game too so you have to take
that incarceration but would you think
about that all right so I sympathize
with her because I think times are
extremely hard right now people are
feeling a lot of fighting to pinch yeah
and so their jobs they count on all
their pay to come in and everything and
when you have bad days you feel the
stress of it uh
I'm gonna say a few things one
your stress shouldn't be directed at
customers it should be directed at the
industry that pays you less than what
you should be paid in order to do the
job that you should be doing it's less
than minimum wage right yep right
nowadays you make it way more than
minimum wage because you're getting big
tips that's the job you desire to enter
that's two I reject the notion that
tipping leads to better service because
if you believe that that means I do
believe that everywhere else we go where
we don't get tips or we don't offer tips
everyone's offering subpar service or
customers that's not been my experience
and so this idea that you are rendering
a service that is somehow deserving of
extra money as if it was better I've
never seen it have y'all so I reject
this notion that tipping leads to better
service that is [ __ ] cap what it
leads to is entitlement
that's what it leads to I've seen
servers get upset at people for not
tipping guess what bro I look at the
bill she mad and there's no tip there's
a gratuity that's already included in
the yeah [ __ ] speak on it yep how are
you gonna expect a tip when you've
already included a tip I tip every time
I go out because that's a social Norm
right I'm not going to be out here
looking crazy I'm not gonna be a [ __ ]
okay I just reject the notion that it
makes the service better or that this is
how it should be like everywhere else
around the world they work it out with
no tips expected but you want to act
like here this shit's normal this is
what we've established in the system
it's a stupid and broken system I play
by the rules because I live here okay
but I don't make any Illusions about oh
the server it's not and you're lying to
yourself if you think it is I know
servers who work at some restaurants
where they're making more than like
people working in medical Fields people
working and they like they make a lot of
money doing service work
that's the highs guess what somebody got
experience the loss but don't get mad at
the regular customer when your employer
is not subsidizing your wage that's
their mistake not ours that's how I'm
going to sign but it is so degrading to
get stiffed
to work so hard to smile at a table with
you have to smile at customers and
pretend like your day is good welcome to
having a job
welcome to having a job whose job do you
think goes into work not feeling great I
don't have to smile and offer good
customer service I think that's America
because that's one thing like we did the
video on America good and bad and [ __ ]
but sometimes the service in America
Jesus Christ do we even like your job do
you even like your job probably they
don't understand life is hard but like
that's welcome to
having no job
I went again I sympathize because I
understand yeah where it's like when
you're not making money and you stress
about your bills but understand
ing this [ __ ] at regular people as if
they're the ones they probably they
might listen oh if you can't afford it
uh you shouldn't go to the spot or maybe
you guys just make a better system to be
honest with you what if you just did
that because I go to restaurants in
Europe all the time they don't have this
[ __ ] so why is that a case here
I don't know to me it's like you got a
busted system you're expecting it to
work for you it hasn't for a very long
time it likely won't in the future as
things get harder financially I know I'm
not mad at the frustration because I
think it's unfair that you get paid four
dollars an hour because people didn't
tip or whatever it is but it's also
because you just didn't get paid
properly by your employer that's the
truth of the matter so that's how I feel
about anything else you want like the
employer that employs you realize on the
customer to pay your wage no that's his
job that's his job that's weird that's
his job so no no it's not his fault I
know it's the customer that don't pay no
the customers pay your your boss and
your boss pays you that's any job that's
any job but hey it is what it is every
time I go to New York and I go to places
and I'm like yeah I say well would you
like I say yes please and thank you and
they're like you're not from around here
I'm like well yeah but yeah well because
I'm polite they're like yeah hey you
know what kills me this is such a bad
words mentality I used to when I was 17
I used to work a sales job it was
basically minimum wage but if you sold a
lot of units yeah you get extra money
yeah and [ __ ] there was weeks where I
was top seller for consecutive months I
was getting that money and there was
other weeks where like yo niggas's
Pockets was tight they couldn't have
money to offer to buy stuff or it wasn't
a good time period for them so I had I
was not making no bonuses and that that
paycheck looked a little Dusty and look
Meek okay
I didn't sit there and think man [ __ ]
these people yo get your money up you
broke I thought to myself I gotta work
harder to be able to make these sales so
the next month my [ __ ] is super tight
getting mad at the regular folks for not
being able to buy into how you get your
extra income seems stupid to me get your
service up there but it's not the same a
bonus is not the same thing as tipping
because the tip is you rely on a
customer to give you a tip based on the
service they receive a bonus is the
company is like hey I made more cash
thanks to you imma cut you some
it's not the same thing it's it's not
it's not the same thing it's the same
same category different degrees
different degree right because I okay
she's making five bucks an hour I'm
making eight okay there's a difference
there absolutely in terms of how much
money there is I'm getting at least a
minimum wage but what I'm trying to say
is I didn't get that extra let's say
well she didn't get that extra my whole
point is your turnaround should not be
oh something's wrong with them they
didn't give me that you should be like
yo how can I work harder how can I do
more and the thing that happened at
least that's the way if it's that
frequent there's there is something
wrong yeah if if you're in a place where
it is known that you're supposed to tip
and that's why I was referenced to
reference referencing to uh your boss
not putting enough people on the floor
right if you're in a spot a workplace in
an area that tipping is a thing
and it happened so frequently that
you don't get your tips
either the service is wrong even either
the food is off either you're not enough
people on the things that takes a long
time for people to get their their their
plates so
I don't know let's think this one
through further a little bit
let's give it a little bit more thoughts
on that one
so let us know what you guys think in
the comments below if you guys agree
disagreed you feel like we were unfair
we want to hear from you